i have always have
compassion more so for the vulnerable
no matter if you're a human animal or
non-human animal i just felt like
leave that person or that animal alone
especially if they can't defend
themselves
because growing up i was a pretty husky
big guy and i was just felt very
passionate about
intervening in these situations where it
just wasn't going to be a good outcome
so
again coming from humble beginnings and
i also experienced a lot of violence
growing up i see my first murder at the
age of five man brains blown out in
front of me
within close distance and i had a big
impact too on my views going forward i'm
really proud that i have been over the
years to help redefine what masculinity
is because masculinity is someone that's
comfortable in protecting as well as
know their own feminine side you're just
basically a human being
doing what human beings should do and
having empathy and protecting and doing
as much as you can to abstain from
harming anything possible and i'm just
very highly alert with my own
sensitivities to that
because i am a guys guy i like a good
vegan burger i like me have a good beer
you know a good drink every now and then
um and and but you can also do that and
participate and be a guy's guy without
harming people or animals that was
dominic thompson a former drug dealer
who grew up with humble beginnings and
unfortunate circumstances including
witnessing his first murder at five
years old after incarceration and
becoming vegetarian in prison he took
his second chance and became a
healthcare executive turned activist and
social impact entrepreneur he's become a
successful vegan multi-sport athlete
who's done triathlons and cares about
many issues spanning from animal rights
to human rights
this authentic and open-hearted
conversation has so many layers with
loads of curiosity and exploring
different ideas and perspectives on how
we can actually show up for positive
change in our individual lives we touch
on so many different topics ranging from
food insecurity in marginalized
communities the problems with our health
care system and prison system and
reincarceration rates
masculinity and compassion his new book
deal eat what elephants eat and so much
more and it felt like we barely
scratched the surface i hope you enjoy
this conversation let's get into it
[Music]
welcome to the podcast dominic thank you
for having me it's an honor for real i
am so excited for the people who are
listening or watching we have purposely
not been discussing the things we want
to talk about today so we can keep it
really fresh and i'm i'm really excited
about this a lot of questions i want to
ask you yeah and i'm an open book i
can't stress that enough i love really
just digging into a lot of things and
topics that can be challenging to some
people and that can be comfort for
comfortable to people so yeah totally
how are you enjoying the island so far
your first time in hawaii absolutely
horrible you know i'm ready to go back
to atlanta i'm kidding
i mean it's a beautiful island full of
great energy uh beautiful people great
food
amazing hikes and i love the fact that
you guys have a lot of different eco
temperatures you know you can have very
hot and humid in one area and you have a
very cool and and wet uh part of the
island so that's pretty the transparent
the transparent uh transition from those
different climates is pretty pretty
amazing yeah there's so many
microclimates here in such a short
distance you can just 30-minute drive
yeah completely different and i know
it's way different here than it is in
georgia yeah what's it like being vegan
in the south uh vegan in itself is not
fun uh but i am not a vegan that eats
out a lot so
you know i
i cook almost every day so it's not that
problematic
but there are people that choose to eat
out a lot and prefer to eat out a lot uh
which is something we're going to talk
about because we're going to help serve
those people with our restaurants that
we're launching so yeah so when is that
you're going to come out with a vegan
restaurant in atlanta in atlanta that'd
be our first launch and we have plans to
move to
a second location in austin and then
we'll go to other
locations in that southeast such as
south florida uh asheville is on there
too
and a couple other places such as
charleston but we're gonna we're gonna
move in the next two to five years
aggressively and strong we was actually
going to launch this quarter of this
year but the pandemic and
what's happening with
servers and employees and more it's just
very hard to get staffing and
this supply disruptions and it's just a
lot of things happening right now it's
just not a good time to launch any type
of
business in that industry uh in my
opinion so we're gonna launch the first
quarter of next year and i'm really
excited about that yeah that makes a lot
of sense i mean the service industry and
restaurant industry is really difficult
in and of itself let alone add on top of
all the things that are going on right
now yeah
yeah pretty busy industry and very it
has its challenges too because of what
happened with the pandemic for sure i
feel like you are so accomplished you've
done so much and are still doing so much
like you got a book coming out which i
know we'll talk about and just with like
just so many um avenues of ventures that
you're doing can you like share about
your vegan story just your even like
your kind of transformation story from
being incarcerated your childhood and to
like what brought you to where you are
today like i would just love to hear
that story yeah um well we gotta go way
back um and
to the audience members i appreciate you
all being here with us because it's
gonna be a lot to really take a deep
dive on uh but it really started at a
very young age i come from very humble
beginnings west side of chicago
lockwood and crystal area to the austin
community
i have always had this big heart and
compassion for animals i was that kid
growing up that
i would have friends you know boys gonna
be boys that would take slingshots and
shoot at squirrels and stray cats and
stray dogs that was just roaming the
streets um and and then there was
different pitbull fights and a lot of
dog fights happening but i'd be that kid
in the middle like no let's leave these
animals alone so i have always have
compassion more so for the vulnerable um
no matter if you're a human animal or
non-human animal i just felt like
leave that person or that animal along
especially if they can't defend
themselves
because growing up i was a pretty husky
big guy and i was just felt very
passionate about
intervening in these situations where it
just wasn't going to be a good outcome
um so
again coming from humble beginnings and
i also experienced a lot of violence
growing up i seen my first murder at the
age of five man brains blown out in
front of me
within close distance and i had a big
impact too on my views going forward
what was that story yeah it was uh you
know my mom
single mother amazing woman um i love my
mama my mom the dog she was working two
jobs she was a nurse
it was three of us and she at times
would need to drop us off at our
grandmother still watch us while she go
what the young kids call today go get a
bag go go get that bag get that money
to keep things on lights on and bills
but she
uh picked us up
from our grandmother and she stayed our
grandmother stayed in the london
community on 16th street
and
it was this drunk driver that hit this
uh
group of girls
and one of the girls
went up at least 10 feet in the air and
he kept going he slowed down and kept
going
uh shortly after and the gang the vice
lords at the time was right there too in
the opposite corner and seeing it unfold
and they just this is back in the 80s
and what people understand about gangs
in the 70s and 80s before it was crack
cocaine and all these other
contrabands of drugs were introduced in
those communities gangs was created to
help empower black communities uh
specifically similar to what
black panthers was before being
designated as a terrorist group or some
type of violent group and also there was
different
influences over the years but the
original gangs of chicago i can't speak
on gangs in la and in different regions
but collectively most black gangs was
created to help empower and and uplift
the youth and communities
to be better men
and this was during that time where they
seen this hit and run
and they retaliated with
automatic weapons and shot up this car
and
that was the first murder i've seen
definitely wasn't the last wow were you
like looking through the window or
something and just saw it all play out
oh my gosh that must have been so
traumatizing
yeah but you know i wasn't
i always been a fearless person
excluding flying
i'm gonna be full transparent i don't
fear anything in this world but flying i
mean you talked about that off record i
do not like flying a body of water and i
think it's mainly because
i'm wired and engineered in logic and to
me there's nothing rational or logic
about flying over body water and this
airbus metal
in this capsule because we're just not
humanly designed to fly and it just i
had my thoughts and critical thoughts
about that um but yeah seeing that
um it would just be the first time i've
seen a murder and again not the last
that would continue to numb me
where it was just becoming the norm
whether you have
friends you grew up with that
was killed and murdered
or
family and loved ones that was killed in
murder or was part of something like
that it was just a lot of violence i
experienced growing up
um but here i am the opposite when it
comes to the variable i like leave these
animals alone
um
and that
was really the start of something that
i always
been about trying to protect or
be involved in something to help
things out in some capacities
um but my start in veganism
if you fast forward i had to go through
some challenges and different things
again i come from a single parent home
no father around as far as to help raise
or contribute financially to
this
family
my mom is just
four of us including my mom
um and you had to
sometimes do things
and go through and experience things
that
is going to get you to that next level
and get you to that next journey or get
past that pothole
um
and the things i did
i used to be
involved in gangs myself
and to understand how that was
influenced on me i grew up in a family
of lieutenants and generals and some
even original architectures of these
gangs very
legendary uncles and cousins that they
was kind of an influence on me but then
i had the positive of this beautiful
strong
kick-ass black woman working two jobs
don't believe in cutting corners don't
believe in complaining just doing what
she needed to do for her and her kids
and i had these two influences
that kind of had influence on me uh
growing up
and i got involved in gangs and i also
got involved in selling drugs to a level
very high level of kilos of cocaine and
stuff like that that eventually
was my demise and landed me uh
years later in federal prison
uh that's where and it was it was
federal prison where i made that
connection
and decided to
go into
this new transition of life um
um of
removing myself from harm specifically
and i remember it was like it was
yesterday
i was sitting in my my jail cell and i i
never been in and out of prison at all
this is my first time ever
being arrested in fact i was in college
i was retired
from the gang and that life and this old
lifestyle basically caught up with me
wow
yeah oh my gosh
that must have been really really
frustrating it was
it needed to happen because like my
lawyer told me that you know this is
i've never at that point up until i was
going through
my legal uh case and and because i
wanted to go to trial it was an
entrapment case it's a
something that me and my lawyer felt
that we can fight on because it was just
basically
a lot of biases that we felt like we can
undo and win
um and in hindsight i feel like we
definitely can have a chat
today's age with so much
people paying attention more to the very
unfair judicial systems we may have a
chance today but back then we didn't you
don't go to war
or fight with the u.s government it's
not the people of hawaii or the people
of the state of maui county or or
wherever you are it's not your county or
the state of your city versus you it's
the united states of america versus you
it's when you feel like you're a
terrorist and an outcast it's one of the
most scary pieces of documents you can
see the people in the united states of
america versus you ella especially if
you don't have the finances to be able
to get a really good lawyer
exactly if you don't have a really good
lawyer you're in a lot of trouble when
it comes to a federal level luckily for
me i was able to fund it pay my lawyer a
lot of money to
take on my case he was a top-of-the-line
lawyer in fact he was referred by at the
time the cochran firm i don't know if
they're still around or anything like
that but he came with high
recommendations
but he said
and
and and had a
man-to-man human human
very
um
kind and direct assertive talk with me
um
one male to another
um and and and said this is the first
time that any
male had this discussion with me he said
listen
we can go to trial and
but if you lose um you're 21 you're not
gonna be home until you're in your 30s
and i'm a first-time offender at this
time
um and he's like you got your whole life
ahead of you you and i both know uh you
know this is what's called he said
listen young man this is what's called
karma i never heard that term karma
before
there's a lot of things i never heard
and experienced
uh up until that point in going forward
but he said this is what's called karma
this is the universe
um really um
sitting you down with the consequences
that you
used to be a part of and you and i both
know
it could be worse you know it can this
is you have to take either go to trial
you risk the losing or you hold your
chin up
and and take full responsibility
and i and i did i took full
responsibility for my actions and that
was
um
the day that would change my life
forever like i i would not be having
this conversation with you and be
having this podcast episode
if i did not go through that part of my
life um
and i was you know i took full
responsibility they basically gave me as
a first-time offender this
ten-year sentence five about four or
five a hard time and then five a house
arrest
and here i am
um in my cell just trying to make sense
of it all cuz i'm young then you know i
was just like it just made no rational
sense to me because i've never been in
trouble i never had a speeding ticket up
into that point
never
ever
been in any trouble with the law and
here i wasn't getting ready to finish
school and everything like that and and
now i'm
serving federal time
and it was then there i decided to get
on my knees and myself
um
i'm not a religious person i didn't grow
up religious at all
i'm more spiritual
but it's it's pretty incredibly
uh humbling
when you're in your darkest times
the way
you call out for help for something more
powerful than you and the universe i i
got on my knees
and i i prayed and
just trying to reach answers and really
connect and i was in that vulnerable
position trying to receive some type of
answers through my calling and energy
and everything pointed to this um
childhood memory when i was eight years
old
um and i remember like it's yesterday my
mom was uh feeding us chicken wings
and i i was always a finicky eater picky
eater and you're a mom you know how boys
can be sometimes or even girls and
um i hated chicken wings with a passion
and i'm looking at these wings at this
time and and i'll always pick through
the tendons of the wings and and just
eat a little bit off the tendency it was
just disgusting and i just remember
looking at the wings and i looked up at
my mom
and then looked back at the wings and i
looked at my arms and looked back at the
wings and i was like i don't want it and
i pushed it to her she's like what's
wrong i was like
they look like little beating arms i
don't want them anymore
and this is in the 80s it's kind of like
my mom's like wait what
what are you talking about what the hell
are you talking about you got to eat
like you you're not going what are you
going to eat and she's like i was like i
don't want those arms and she was like
hmm
and it's kind of hard and it can be
intimidated to tell a
single mother
that buster has to put what she can on
the table like you know we living in
very poor and we was poor no no doubt
about it we was poor yeah and
um but she told me well you're not gonna
eat my mom was always a no nonsense
straight assertive straight shooter but
i'mma chip off her block she always
taught me to speak my mind and i was
like well then i'm not gonna eat
and we had like this standoff and but
then she eventually compromised and went
to the store to buy me fish sticks
[Laughter]
it was kind of like masking this
um the anatomy of the animal
specifically it was easy and again you
have boys and
most children
what are we talking fish sticks or
chicken nuggets
prefer that than something that's tied
to like a bone structure and then they
start asking a question like where does
bone come from where this animal comes
from
kids no it's their intuition
so this memory popped in my head like a
light bulb right there in my cell as i'm
you know praying
and it went off like i was like i get it
i get it
um
everything started making sense this
this un
known messaging went in my head like i
knew like a light bulb and and then i
created this mattress right there for
myself
that if it requires harm then no i don't
have it i want to have anything to do
with it
and right then i just denounce
eating meat any any time like i i became
instantly right then and there uh
vegetarian because by then vegetarianism
was integrated similar to veganism
i didn't know about the dairy industry
but i stopped eating meat
uh you know and i made that promise to
the universe i would never eat meat
again and i never looked back and that
was
20 close to 21 22 years ago yeah wow
that is crazy that it took you being in
a prison cell
and like when you're being there by
yourself all you have are your thoughts
yeah that's when that transformation
happened for you and you're seeing
not even just about like animals but
you're just saying like oh the overall
arching theme is like do no harm yeah
yeah wow that's really powerful yeah
it's and i always tell people whether
when i'm traveling given my own speaking
engagements and more that i feel like
most humans think they know themselves
but the ones that really do know
themselves when they are at the darkest
moment and hit rock bottom or those that
are serving time and for incarceration
for whatever reason or soldiers off at
war because when you're close to death
and you're just at that point that
breaking point you really
make sense of a lot of things and
decisions you made up into that point
and then you realize there's only one
way to go up and everything pointed in
this direction of do no harm
and i like and i know a lot of us that
are
in this lifestyle of
plant-based vegan whatever you define
yourself as
don't talk about how the spiritual
impact how the energy is just ascending
from there as the universe took me i was
supposed to be in there for five years
the universe got me out there got me out
of prison early and everything has been
like a uphill beautiful ascent ever
since then how long did you serve i
started about three yeah and what was it
like eating vegetarian in prison like
did you like have to tell your prison
guards like hey i'm vegetarian no yeah
i'm sure it's different so it's probably
definitely different these days you can
be classified by religion and more but
back then you didn't have that choice i
would trade my
carbs
with my
cell mates um i mean not my carbs i'm
sorry cherry my meat based protein with
my cell mates for their carbs and i
would eat a lot of complex and simple
carbs and they used to look at me
like you sure died i was like yeah
that's like
and they they're like that's that that's
that crazy that's that weirdo you know
that's where the name of my first
company crazies and weirdos came up from
because they used to think i was crazy
and weird
not to be eating meat and i'm like
giving them whatever
meat that we was being served on the
line
giving it to them and they like i'll
take it and they're like you want these
potatoes you want this pasta this rice
and these veggies they don't want that
and i was like yes give it to me and
this is before the documentaries this is
before the book it just was intuition
and i didn't know what the hell i was
doing i don't know if i was going to
wither away or not i just know that
whatever this experiment i'm going
through this is what the universe is
telling me to do and i'm never going to
be a part of anything that was alive
again
wow yeah well that's fascinating the
whole time when i because i i have known
that you ate vegetarian in prison i'm
just picturing that it was like
um a thing that was able to be catered
to
obviously i don't understand i didn't
have a clue but that's really really
cool and fascinating that you're like
literally trading your meals with other
people and they're like okay you're
weird but okay yeah you're wave that's
what you want to eat then go ahead sir
and and so i had and what what happened
next over the next couple months
when i entered prison i was this big
husky guy kind of
a lot of inflammation and overweight and
stuff just from the good life you know
the drug dealing good life in in general
and that inflammation was gone that
overweight was gone within like two
months i went down i went from being
like over 250 pounds all the way down at
my lowest i think i was like 187. you
know my abs was showing i became
stronger i became one of the top
uh
inmates that were out we was on a
compound of
maybe over a thousand inmates and we
would have what's called liftoffs and i
was one of the top 10 strongest guys in
there like i was
killing it from benching over 405 to
squatting easily 500 pounds to
deadlifting like close to 500 pounds to
deadlift and over 500 like is nothing so
yeah were you surprised by that result
like because obviously you didn't go
into it with that kind of expectation
no i wasn't really surprised because
again this is a young dominic and
we didn't have access to the supplement
industry we didn't know what the all
these um
predatory uh practices and um
bias propaganda that the supplement
industry pushes out there even to this
day so i it's not like i was conditioned
to believe
i need like anything between creatine to
protein powders i so i wasn't surprised
but it was just
i always been a strong guy but it was it
was just an interesting time and it was
the and i tell people this all this time
it was the closest
that i felt to becoming like a real
superhero like i mean
you just feel different yeah you sleep
better you feel different
your confidence is
the energy i just can't explain you
really feel like
you're at your highest peak of a human
being as far as health loss and this is
not even you getting high quality food
exactly
i'm getting complex carbs and simple
carbs and not
i wasn't definitely getting enough
vegetables but this is definitely just
i we would need i would have to so there
was a time where i i wanted more
vegetables but they wasn't serving it to
us but they were serving it to the the
guards
and so i would uh pay
whoever was working in the kitchen to
serve the guards on their lunch breaks
um through stamps uh actually to get
tomatoes and bell peppers and stuff
that's amazing yeah i mean because
that's the only way we have access to it
um yeah and other assets too was on
commissary so i would spend all the
little money that
my mom didn't have much money to see me
no one a lot of people turned it back
and i didn't have much money on
commissary but the little money i have i
would spend on like vegetables yeah for
sure and fruit a lot of fruit i bet that
must have been even more weird to people
that like that's what you're bringing in
to prison versus like spending your you
have the opportunity on commissary to
buy chips ice cream yeah
all types of stuff processed foods that
is not healthy for you
but yeah here i was just trying to my
body was just like i was just flowing uh
organically in a sense that my body just
knew this is what it needed and i was
just buying it so then take me to the
part where you get out of prison and
you're like this transformed person yeah
like what's where's your mindset there
ah man my mindset was actually different
when i got out um sure
i it was it was a great thing but and
people don't understand when you come
out of
being locked up for a while like i've
been through
different levels of security in prison
and my most high level security was when
i was 40 days in a hole in 40 nights
when i
this
coward hit me from behind
with a chair and
long story short it was a fight that
incurred but it knocked me out but since
i wouldn't
tell him him or be honest about who hit
me because i wanted to deal with him in
my own manner
the way that i was
conditioned to believe was a great you
know with violence you respond with
violence different mindsets back then
but that put me in the hole um holly
will always get prison inaccurate it's
not
this happening over here or this
happening over here you know but one
thing hollywood has been kind of
accurate on is when you go to the hole
where you have no ventilation and air
coming to you you have no light coming
to you and you got these
multiple steel doors so i that was the
most that i've been through
but it made me stronger
but with that being said when i
re-entered society
it was a different
feeling because even seeing cars go by
would make you nauseous and dizzy
hearing
music and you just have a different
sensitivity to things
so i was more like militant i was more
like angry
at myself at the world i didn't want to
hear any type of music that i grew up on
from rap music to nothing i didn't want
to see no type of nonsense i was just
like
grandpa more like an angry
grandfather i mean can you blame anyone
for getting out of prison especially if
you've stayed in what you said the whole
like yeah when it like you said
hollywood obviously does depict that and
whenever i see that depicted in movies
it literally looks like the most
miserable thing that you can it is the
most
not even to have any kind of view you're
completely by yourself like just the way
that it's like depicted in the way you
described it sounds
like something that you wouldn't want to
wish on your worst enemy
i say to this day i wouldn't wish going
through what i went through and most
people that experience incarceration
especially the first time offenders you
have people that repeat and repeat
by the way i've never been back since
then yeah yeah but i think that's clear
yeah that's clear um but like i tell
most people i wouldn't wish that my
worst enemy however however
we you you had to make the best of your
situation sure there wasn't jobs in
there there wasn't um training or
education in there
that shows you what we do with our
taxpayer money that shows you how
um
very
wrong in many capacities the
multi-billion dollar prison and judicial
system is
not doing anything for humans
specifically that truly want to
rehabilitate
i made the best of my situation by
reading a lot of books and writing and
getting my body back in top shape
but even though i wouldn't wish that on
my worst enemy if i had to do it again i
would because it made me a better human
being and i tell people that all the
time because there's no telling where i
would be right now like it just made me
a better human being and appreciate
life for what it is just the simplest
things by having a casual conversation
with you to me is a beautiful thing and
some people
take advantage of life not realizing
life is pretty pretty special a lot of
times it's your lowest moments that like
in the moment it feels like why is this
happening how could this happen to me
like it's never going to get better and
i can't see any good coming from this
and then later you look back and you're
like
oh that had to happen in order for me to
get here for you
to really hit some peaks right
and that doesn't mean that i feel like
it's such a delicate thing because like
for someone who's gone through something
like sexual trauma or like a child lost
like how could you say that you know
like that had to happen so i feel like
it's a very layered thing but there's so
many things instances within my life
where it's like i look back and i'm like
in the moment i was like this is the
worst thing ever and yeah and then later
you're like i'm so glad that happened
yeah for sure you're right everyone
deals with their traumas and challenges
and experiences different
um and all i always tell people i teach
this to people that listen there's only
one way you can go from that trauma or
that experience and that's forward
staying in that one position is going to
continue to be painful and you
definitely want to get pushed and when
you have the wall against your back you
can't go no further so you just got to
go up and forward yeah yeah so you got a
prison you have this like tough mindset
and like just to see where you've got
become now where you're like a
passionate animal rights activist but
also human rights activists and do you
feel like a lot of that is largely in
part to like what you've experienced
absolutely absolutely it was based on my
own experiences growing up what i seen
the system for what it was god i had a
chance to do my own unpacking and
educate myself in many capacities
um and see truly how
different biases are placed in society
uh
what are we talking people on the left
the people on the right there's just a
lot of people in very powerful positions
to really shape the canvas of what
people sometimes do go through because
we are
bound to certain systems and industries
in order to participate to be
sustainable and live you know so i i had
a chance to really um
learn a lot too from my own cases my own
case in itself from the sentencing
guidelines being
very unfair practices
being pushed off on
most
young black men because you won't find
crack cocaine in like suburban areas
specifically in america you'll find
powder cocaine which is what i got uh
indicted for
but you'll find crack cocaine
in the 80s in most
communities of colors and marginalized
communities and those
sentencing guidelines were created and
architected by people such as
biden and moore more
individuals
very unfairly to punish first-time
offenders and don't matter
very highly where they feel like crack
cocaine at that time was more potent
than powder cocaine it's actually the
opposite
you know and when you think about the
logic i mean you're watering down powder
cocaine with baking soda yeah
and then you have this powder cocaine
that's it's more potent but you're going
to send it to somebody that's caught
with the more the poor man's version
it just makes no logical sense so i took
what i learned and understood from that
and growing up
and just applied it and tried my best to
educate people and make them aware that
this is what's happening in these
industries in these communities and
especially with the judicial system
yeah for sure it's interesting how a lot
of people kind of brush over that like
binding was a big part of this 1994
crime bill yeah
um
yeah but there's like there's so many
layers to it because there has been
improvements but it doesn't it doesn't
seem to have gotten far enough to where
it's almost like a little too late too
little too late and while there are
things that definitely needed to happen
anyways like the first step act that
happened
which like helped people to be able to
um revisit and try to get revisions
basically so that they could get out of
prison earlier
yeah to be able to get out of prison
early a lot of a lot of people did get
out of prison early but still still
people saving time that haven't gotten
out of prison especially when it comes
to the marijuana laws and stuff now that
marijuana and tac is more commercially
socially accepted
and you have more states adopting this
revenue
practice of legalization and they're
making a lot of money from it but you
have a lot of people from back in the
day
um
still serving time or still had that
felony on their record but then you have
this
big 98 of people from ventura
capitalists to local governments to
international governments so many
different parties and special interest
groups making money now for something
that
these people back in the day this is the
only way they knew how to make money
it's a hustle and there's original plant
pushers of that with yeah with that and
it's definitely it it is unfair in some
capacities too yeah absolutely there
there is um the equal act that did
recently pass this lap september in the
house with near unanimous um like um
bipartisan
consent um but it hasn't passed in the
senate yet so that's hopefully that
passes but like i said it's like it
feels too little too late and it's like
really unfortunate how many people that
impacted yeah a lot of communities
communities been affected the war on
drugs
um
is is something that
a lot of us from our timeline would
never forget because
and those that do choose to forget it or
don't know it you don't really become
passionate or activate your own activism
yourself until it has an impact on your
house your home your your partner your
brother your uncle your father when you
start seeing these people being uh
missing and and
going through some challenges uh legally
that they just have no way out of and
and you see the very unfair practices of
the judicial system it gets personal and
it's very personal so what would you
like to see change what do you think
would help would help this system that
has so many problems i think we're
definitely moving forward with
i would like to see federally
more
policy change blanket right because you
can have one state
where this record might be expunged and
or this person like someone like me
my gun rights are done you know i can't
i can't bear a gun because i have a
felony not to say i i'm pro-gun and i'm
not trying to get a gun but just in
general you lose from floating right you
lose all these rights as a yeah human
being when you as a first-time offender
so i think yeah
a lot of that stuff needs to be um in
general if the whole judicial system
needs to be dismantled and broken down
and rebuilt very fairly and and
and we need to have truly people that
are not uh being lobbied with special
interest groups to continue to impose
things that just simply are unfair to
certain groups in certain communities
yeah the lobbying power of industries
really messes things up it does it
really really does like things that
could potentially or mostly be fair and
free
it ends up messing things up because of
power and money and lobbying abilities
so i yeah i agree i definitely think
that like
the um
amount that people can lobby or interest
groups can lobby like definitely needs
to be changed for so many different
things
money definitely
influences and buys
new policies
and leaves behind a lot of people that
simply cannot fight these policies don't
have the resources or even the advocacy
like for example even what's happening
with most americans don't know when you
eat pork most of the time you're
supporting you're supporting
environmental racism because most of
that pork is sourced from the tar heel
country of america the carolinas
where these factory farms are
strategically placed in these poor royal
communities of color and they don't have
the resources the advocacy or the the
power to fight big factory farms from
putting this there and what's happening
those lagoons are spilling over into the
communities from those pigs and those
hogs and they're becoming the highest
demographic demographics being admitted
to the hospitals for these cancers
everything from
asthma to sinuses and more even unc did
a study where they swapped the outside
of the house and even the kitchens to
see feces wow feces on these homes yeah
i think people a lot of people don't
even realize just how much animal poop
there is
in america like let's talk specifically
america because that's what we're
relating to right now sure so how much
that animal poop runoff is going into
the rivers that's running down and
emitting
so much
not good things like i don't know the
right term for it but the
the things that are potentially causing
cancer and the cancer belt essentially
sure the higher rates of that especially
when you digest it you're digesting
carcinogens yeah and stuff in it the
beautiful thing is the science is
finally catching up you can't like i'm
science driven and and the data is there
men lie women live humans lie but data
does not lie yeah absolutely so yeah
i mean there's so many things that could
be changed something that really comes
to mind with me about the prison system
is like the reincarceration rate and how
hard it is to get a leg up when you get
out you do you're you're discriminated
against for sure between big employer
groups to
more it was
look honestly it was worse than i i feel
like there's been progress yeah i
definitely did there's a lot of
companies
from small startups to
even corporations that simply don't care
if you made a mistake i mean obviously
if you made a violent mistake where you
like someone that
is definitely a evil person and you took
a life
for whatever reason
that's different you know there's
different crimes out there where people
just simply won't forgive you
but those that the war on drugs and
those are drug offenders and people
that's just was brought up in these
communities
to just try to make something out of
nothing
because they wasn't even given the
opportunity because there's not
back then there wasn't the structure the
infrastructure for uh employment you
know and this is the best way they knew
or this is way some people was
conditioned to believe this is that you
can make money
a lot of these companies are a little
bit more forgiving now too so we
definitely made progress i don't want to
dismiss that yeah we for sure have made
progress for sure even in the like law
and federal level like um in the last
administration it was kim kardashian
obviously she can't take like full
credit but she was part of helping
facilitate like prison reform to help i
think it was something about helping um
inmates who got out of prison to be able
to have a ride to work yeah something
about that so little things like that
yeah yeah and
i think about actually i took a
sociology of women's class in college
and it was my favorite class in all of
colleges this professor dr leonard who
passed away now but she was super
passionate about
women who had gone to prison for killing
their abusers
and how i'm not sure about the law now
but at the time
back when i took this class the law was
that if a woman was up against a man and
she
didn't have a weapon
that was considered equal equal combat
right like self-defense but if she had a
weapon and the man didn't then that was
not considered self-defense whereas we
all know that no matter the situation
like no matter how strong a woman is
majority of the time you don't have a
weapon to defend yourself against a man
yeah like you're gonna lose you're
definitely gonna lose so yeah so she was
really passionate about helping these
women get out of prison and um not have
to have the sentences that they have
gotten a lot of them life in prison for
things like this defending themselves
yeah or even if they're in like a life
or death situation where
the partner or the abuser
should say partner but the abuser is um
like threatening the life of them or
their child that they're with and they
try to escape and the abuser brings them
back and they're literally so hopeless
and because there's not
um at least at the time like systems in
place to help them then they end up yeah
different remedies and solutions so many
layers yeah so she ended up taking us to
a prison to meet some of the women and
they're in these inmates and we met this
woman
and she was like the sweetest woman so
nice and she had been doing her studies
she graduated college within prison and
like kind of what you said about like
reading books and sure um had gotten so
accomplished and after we left
everyone's like that lady was so sweet
she was so nice who was that lady and
she's like that was leslie van houten
she was one of the manson girls
and it was just so great she had been in
prison her whole life and she's like
very very very old now and that's not to
say anything about you know my thoughts
on her sentence or her whatever but it
was just so fascinating to see like what
transformation you can make in prison
and so i think you're right there has
been um adjustments and things that have
helped but we still it sounds like have
a long way to go no we we do have a long
way to go and and that's fair and uh
look people make mistakes people
sometimes get
vacuumed and
brainwashed into different things and
it's tough to be
i
it's a thin line too like we live in
such a
culture now where people are easily
counseling people and judging people for
every little thing you can say hey ellen
the sky is beautiful out here it's sunny
and there's somebody like no it's not
it's technically purple or just a baja
like these very angry people that don't
want
things to be at peace some people really
thrive
off of chaos and disruption
um and you definitely want to stay away
from those people but with that being
said people do make mistakes people do
change um i mean look at you yeah look
at me i wasn't i i was not the most
pleasant guy you want to be around back
in the day
i know it feels like there should be
more opportunity for not having to have
a sentence that you did however many
decades ago or however long ago like
still be on your like record for
everyone to see every time you try to
apply somewhere where it follows you
around everywhere yeah it's hard it's
hard to know like what the right answer
is yeah it's it's really it's definitely
a complex topic
but i think the amount of money that we
spend in other areas we you know we move
digital currency around like it's
nothing right yeah i mean
thinking that we don't have the money
for this stuff we do and and that whole
concept but we're in debt and we can't
make things happen we see what what we
just was able to fund through what we
went through in different capacities
some of that funding can be allocated to
better programming for people that do
make mistakes in in those scenarios they
shouldn't have to go through a hard time
and they should be able to go through
and have options to really want to
become a better human um and i get it
some people feel like well that's not
fair you can commit a crime and come out
with a diploma or you know a degree but
no i mean the goal should be if someone
that has that thought process like you
should see it's a lot of forever
yeah but like
i feel like the thought process should
be hey we want to help you so that your
life is transformed and that you aren't
you know going back to those same old
ways and like you can't expect someone i
mean
we all have personal responsibility
that's a huge part of it but like
wouldn't we want to help i don't know
what do you expect them to do like yeah
once they're hit rock bottom right what
is the option for that human yes exactly
there's a lot of i think a lot of people
don't relate and so there's it's hard to
empathize right and that's why stories
like yours are so powerful sorry what
we're gonna say yeah no and i and i
agree and i hope people receive what
we're talking about with open heart and
kindness
to realize you shouldn't have to go
through what i went through or anyone
else went through to understand that we
all are humans we are trying to figure
out this
big beautiful complex thing we call life
you know we make mistakes we all come
from different backgrounds i say it all
the time some people hear me say this
but there are you know close to eight
billion people in this world that's
going to wake up tomorrow with eight
billion different points of views
that's diversity and that's beautiful in
itself you know and we we can't be all
uniform with our alliology you know
whether you're on the left right middle
you have to understand that people just
have different opinions
i so agree nuances is so important and
not like labeling people like oh you
disagree with me so you're this just
like try to understand each other yeah
try and receive it with an open heart
don't be rooted so much in your own
biases because your lifestyle i think
that's what happens with so many people
people are if they practice a certain
lifestyle they're going to be biased and
just dismiss you or try to shame you or
just feel like well
you know your way is just wrong you know
and we don't receive that with open
heart and we just need to be more kind
and receive that people just live
different lives and have different
opinions and they should
[Music]
and now a few words from our sponsor who
helps make this show possible
whenever guests stay in our home they
are always amazed after their first
night of sleep and ask where the bedding
is from because it's so incredibly soft
i tell them it's from buffy and they're
pleasantly surprised to hear the bedding
is sustainably made from eucalyptus
the bedding industry has a huge impact
on the environment but buffy decide to
change that their products are made
using only renewable and recycled
materials which makes them as soft on
the planet as they are on your bed their
debut product the cloud comforter is
covered in super soft eucalyptus fabric
and filled with fluffy fiber made from
100 recycled bottles it has over 18 000
5 star reviews and it is hands down the
best comforter i've ever slept with the
cloud comforter is ultra breathable
softer than cotton and it keeps you at
the perfect temperature to feel cozy
without overheating and my husband can
attest to this plus it's hypoallergenic
and also machine washable the average
down comforter harms 12 geese but
buffy's comforter is cruelty free it
feels even softer than down while
keeping about 50 bottles out of
landfills and oceans and eucalyptus uses
10 times less water than cotton to grow
so use my code ellen for dollars off
orders over eighty dollars you can try a
comforter in your own bed for free if
you don't love it return it at no cost
i mean where should we go from here i
feel like you can you can continue how
about continue to tell me a little bit
more about after you got out of prison
like what sure yeah yeah yeah the chunk
up there's definitely a big space there
so when i got out you know i had to
serve house arrest um
and
you know i had to get back on my feet
and i had you know had a curfew i my
curfew had to be in the house by like 7
00 p.m and i wasn't able to leave the
house until like 7 00 a.m
um and that time that i was able to
leave the house was either needed to be
searching for jobs well first of all the
halfway house because i was in a half
house for about six months
it's the transition
um but i was able
to
get back on my feet and get into health
care
um so my first position right when i got
indicted i had an entry level position
working in health care
um for a cbo office of a health system
doing revenue cycle and management and
collections and i i
was able to really clean up the ar to a
point that i was averaging one to five
million in in revenue cleanup for this
health system
a quarter of the year that i made such
an impact that
uh and i was fully transparent with them
when i got indicted because i mean i was
arrested and gone for five days but then
i got out on bond and had to go to the
pre-trial and all of that so i was out
but i needed to still be productive
while i was dealing with my my case and
i went to
my directors and was honest with them
but i made such a impact with them to
women by the way
this is going to sound biased
but i got to tell you
um to me and this is my this this is me
being honest and transparent about my
own bias your own bias um that i women
are the best kick-ass leaders in the
world like
like i have such a big heart for
women in leadership roles women in any
powerful role of influence because
women just to me based on my experience
and what i'm going to tell you you're
all going to appreciate this see things
differently and sure we have a small
percentage of guys
that have that empathy you know what i
mean
but most men
don't really uh
really
have that empathy that's just organic
and nurturing like most women and these
two women i went to
that was my bosses one was a black woman
one was a white woman
nate
regina may she rest in power right now
and kim
as well
they
i told them what happened i'm straight
up honest with them and
they come from challenging backgrounds
too they have their own little story
and they said well listen you are
we're going to keep you you're gonna
work here until whatever happens and you
just you know your case
but
if we are around in our positions
when you come home you have a you have a
home here you have a job wow yeah
that's amazing yeah wow oh my gosh what
a difference that made it was a big
difference because when i got home i
definitely looked them up and it was
there and they had to go these women had
to fight with hr and the legal
department and they had to always go to
the c-suite of executive
to
yeah because here i am a felon right but
they're [ __ ] they're fighting they're
fighting like this is not a violent
felon this is a
situation that happened he was
transparent he was honest
and it took them like six months to
prove this but i got approved and
because because
you came
one thing anyone could say about me that
had the opportunity to work with me in
corporate america like um i still have
some of those relationships um
i i'm a really effective worker i'm
really productive uh and i took that
opportunity put it in the headlock and i
shot up and ran to the point that
i was negotiating their workers comp
claims and i escalated started you know
started working for the sister company
and started negotiating physician
contracting and and then hospital
contract i just kept elevating into
health care from this one opportunity i
was given a second chance you took your
chance and you took the chance
without a college degree too right
without a college degree excelling while
running
different markets in the region that i
never looked back and you also proved to
all the people who are skeptical of you
that these women fought for you for like
yeah i'm good for like you basically
they vouched for you and you completely
improved it wow they vouch for me and
that and that just shows to tell you
anyone that you want to take a chance on
and you know that's a good person and
they just need it
life is sometimes about who you know and
they can help you out these women took a
chance on me
and
i took that opportunity and didn't let
them down yeah you know i mean and i
excel into this one you know it's no
longer living the other one is super
proud of me like she's seen this young
guy excel
and take on these opportunities and so a
former co-worker on my
was telling
told a vp at this bigger
on the other side so i work for a huge
health system called
vanguard
and then
this other colleague went to this other
huge health care company and was like
you know you should you need to get him
he's great at physician contracting he
understand contract law and all of that
um and my ex used obviously i feel like
i was a lawyer in a different lifestyle
i just understand contracting i
understand business development it's
just a very complex system and then
you're dealing with drgs revenue codes
and medicare laws that people simply
can't comprehend and i knew it like the
back of my hand i could tell you so much
about health the health system
from public health to
revenue to
preventive care and bit i can tell you
so much that will blow your mind and
and i knew this stuff and so this
company flew me down like hey
uh and i'm skipping a little bit over
the fact that i had to deal with house
arrest so i would do my
job and come home and be on house arrest
and it was a recycle i couldn't go to
the gym i could do nothing i would just
do push-ups in my place
uh i stayed i found me i was able to get
live in a three-bedroom apartment
on the west side of chicago and sure it
was in in the hood but it was my place
you know what i mean it was my first
place
uh
making uh um
a living in healthcare
um but i was we didn't have social media
back then yeah right we didn't have like
dating apps either we had none of this
stuff we had blockbuster video yes i
remember i definitely remember
yeah we just had blockbuster video and
it was so funny because uh
my mom at the time
um uh
rescued this little fur ball from she
will every year go to saint thomas
island because her husband is from st
thomas uh they met at work and they got
married uh he waited until i came home
to marry her which was nice of him
because i walked her down the aisle
and so
this little fur ball
that she rescued and
she would call this little dog into the
bed and he had chihuahuas and chihuahuas
was like evil imagine gremlins right so
you got stripe you know
ganging up on gizmo right
and she was like you know fighting with
him and he's like well that's her
brothers and sisters and
this little dog just didn't get along to
chihuahua so why was i very different
let's just be honest they're different
and
and uh she was telling me about this
problem i was like well you know here
i'm on house arrest and i can only go to
work and it's not like i can i had no
life you know like in no social life in
capacity and i said well bring over i
didn't know what type of dog she was
going to bring over i was like just how
about i raise her cause i i raced a
couple of dogs growing up
and she's like i said i keep her first
couple months and she get older she's a
puppy and she's like okay so she brought
over on a saturday and my mom opened the
door
and i was like where's she at she was
like right here and i looked and just
between her legs was this little bitty
fur ball with the biggest
pixlr eyes that you can imagine that
disney can create and something like
this these big beautiful brown eyes and
i looked and i scooped this little dog
up
and i just started smiling and it was
the first time my mom seen me crack a
smile since coming home from prison she
felt like prison took my soul and she
started crying right instantly and i was
like it's okay man i was like what's her
name she was like she named rasoka after
the dance the official dance of saint
thomas called the soccer
and and i was like all right i'm gonna
raise soka for a couple months i'll give
her back to you never gave it back
this is
for everyone out there that follows me
no that was my fur daughter scruff mcfly
that was her online persona
but this little bitty dog
this beautiful little soul is what kind
of
made me view
things even more critical with respect
to animals
people don't really understand just how
intelligent animals can be yeah they can
read you you can read them me and her
communicate so this little beautiful
princess would wait on her dad uh come
over that she'd be excited and here we
were on both on house arrest
and watching our movies she's like this
is great dad we are like wrestling in
the bed we'll be on the couch watching
movies and sliding through my wood
floors like my my ghetto wood floors and
we it was just me and her i'd get down
and wrestle her and we just created the
best
friendship um
that was my best friend um
i lost her last year but
she was uh yeah so i try not to cry
every time i think talk about it but
that was my best friend
um
and here was my best friend
i flew down going back to the whole
healthcare story uh
this vp flew me down to tennessee uh
because now i'm off of house arrest at
this point uh i did two years of house
arrest and me and my lawyer went to the
federal judge and show that i'm a role
model citizen and he was like i always
knew you had it in you very fair judge
he was
a very fair guy i think
you know he wasn't biased on either side
um and but he
spoke on he's like i knew you always had
it in you and he commuted the rest of my
sentence and he was like you know you're
not doing five years
you're done everything is paid for
that's awesome it was a yeah it's a
great and i appreciate him for doing
that
um and so here i am now in tennessee
being an interview for this bigger
position to make six figures
um to run tennessee and georgia and the
vp was blown away by me and and offered
me the job on the spot and i was like i
gotta go home and talk to
my kid my fur kid she's a decision maker
so i flew back home and i told you that
all right dad let's do this you know
like
this dude so i packed up my u-haul and
put on my truck and me and baby girl
drove to nashville
for what was going to be
the start of a whole new career and i'm
making six figures running part of
tennessee
and and and more and so i was in
healthcare for years i uh
15 plus years 10 uh 15 years
and
what happened next was an acquisition
that eventually took me to atlanta then
another acquisition
where my boss at the time asked me to go
to new york
i didn't want to go to new york because
i'm from chicago i'm from a big city and
i feel like new york was chicago on
steroids i just didn't want to i felt
like i was going backwards and i was
comfortable
right in atlanta
um working i had my own office i had my
own gym within that building of that
office and i was i was not not bad for a
guy
a felon yeah making six figures look
what i came from this kid from five year
old seen his first murder humble
beginnings and now i'm making good money
and he's like you know no pressure i
want you to go up there and at the time
my ex
um
she uh
had a position she just got offered at a
firm in new york she i met her when she
was in law school in georgia and she
went back up there because she's an
intern for them and
she was like
calling me like you know she was on a
lot of pressure because she was doing
these real estate deals her clients was
bank of america and chasing these multi
100 million dollar deal she'll come home
at four o'clock in the morning
to her little small wall street
apartment she's like i need you up here
babe this is not gonna work if you don't
come up here
she's like what the [ __ ] are you waiting
on i was like what do you mean she was
like
i'm telling you get up here your boss is
telling you get up and she's like and
she just straight up
gave me
uh ultimate she was like listen this
long distance is not going to work if
you don't come up here we're just not
going to work i need you up here
your boss needs you up here
i was like all right let me talk to
ahsoka you know which was her you know
her mom she her and silva had a great
relationship and and so
daughter so that was sulka's mom and uh
and i'm right here with soka like
all right your mom needs us uh you know
and my job needs me up here she's like
ah fine let's go to new york
[Laughter]
so i i put my truck in storage and we
got a u-haul and we was off the nyc and
here is we we settled in the nyc me her
and my ex
and again me reflecting on
what i've been through here i am
standing in this doorman building uh
making good money and my partner making
good money i was like life ain't so bad
this is crazy like i'm i was given a
second chance the universe right and i
took that opportunity to continue to be
consistent and be fair and kind
and that was the first time ellen that i
was able to really exhale
to really like
you know like i spent all my dirty still
dealing with the judicial system and
trying to get on my feet and here i was
like i think i was 32 at the time in new
york
looking
um
and reflecting on my life and the
childhood friend of me he called me up
he's like you know you should get on
this cool new app all the cool kids on
and you know you always talk about
veganism and stop eating animals and you
should kind of blog and i was like what
is blogging yeah he was like yeah
blogging man i was like i didn't know
these terms i was like he's like you'll
figure out just download this alcohol
instagram it's like insta what
this is when instagram first came out
yeah and i was like all right dude
whatever man he's like trust me man this
is the future i know you he knew it he
knew it and i downloaded this app and i
was just like
people doing selfies i was so against
this this is like early on instagram
when people was using filters and it was
chronological order and if you had 3 000
followers it was like thirty thousand
followers yeah thirty thousand followers
like three hundred thousand different
different times way different people
don't think social media is gonna be
sustainable and i created an account and
i just myself i started talking about
what i knew of
animal agriculture and the healthcare
system that i worked in and how
preventive care is important what you
eat is important early on in those
captions and my account just took off
organically because we didn't have very
many vegan men at that time especially
in men of color we only have
the stereotype back then was of a vegan
male was two types both was white guys
either in middle age
ultra endurance athlete like a rich role
you know and by the way me and rich are
very close and we came out around the
same time but i was the anti-rich role
[Laughter]
i was a former gangster no nonsense
straight up due to size outlet you and
your mama together like no just no
nonsense the opposite and and also the
opposite the other stereotype was either
like some hippie
psychedelic pothead guy from australia
with blue eyes surfing and i was the
opposite and the community accepted me
and and i just i remember i've been
following you for ages yeah because my
instagram was very similar like just
happened very organically i was just
sharing my life like my kids fresh food
and that's the most beautiful way when
you're just being yourself yeah i wasn't
trying to be anything
myself yeah still not trying to be
anything it just took off but it's so
different it's so difficult social media
it's so different now it's a business
now it's it's driven by so much
including capitalism and more but
we do have to make money and i get it uh
but i thought what better way to use
this platform now than to
raise more awareness and that's how i
became who i became just more active and
going to disruptions and fighting for
animal rights and human rights i used my
platform because at that time i did have
the largest vegan mail account at that
time and i thought what better way to do
that just to educate people so much of
what i know i'm sure you implement a lot
of people i did it was crazy when did
you become vegan uh so i became vegan
around the time i transitioned to new
york yeah yeah and new york listen as
much as i was against going to new york
i was i was like [ __ ] new york
i was just like didn't want to do it
new york
uh has his pros and his cons but new
york definitely made
me who i was with it activated the
activism i mean it's just something just
like you guys have this energy on the
island here new york has a different
energy on their island
it's just a different it's truly the
concrete jungle for sure so you becoming
you know
having a larger following on instagram
people following you loving what you're
about and how different like you'd like
you said like a total different
stereotype of veganism
what are your thoughts on like veganism
and masculinity and and even like
masculinity and compassion because i'm
sitting here listening you talk about
your sweet little innocent dog and how
much love you have for this little tiny
creature and kind of the stereotype of
like masculine like what's masculine is
just not that yet here you are so
masculine yeah and how could anyone
refute that so what what are your
thoughts on that yeah i think
we
masculinity in itself um
has
been hijacked by a lot of different
personalities and influencers and
different entities and industries you
got to be a guys guy you got to destroy
and destroy or
you know eat meat and be this certain
image of this
guy that's just
sitting up shooting up things or eating
a big ass burger and steak and even like
now it goes to the like eating the like
liver and the even balls and different
urine just like eating it raw and like
that's what a man's man carnivore diet
yeah like that's what a man that we're
going back to our our days and our
origins and that's just so much
misinformation and ignorance in that in
itself to me uh i i'm really proud that
i have been over the years to help
redefine what masculinity is because
masculinity is someone that's
comfortable in protecting as well as
know their own feminist side i think
women can have masculinity and feminism
and men can have masculinity and
feminism you are just basically a human
being
doing what human beings should do and
having empathy
and protecting and doing as much as you
can to abstain from harming anything
possible and i'm just very highly alert
with my own uh sensitivities to that uh
because i am a guys guy i like a good
vegan burger i like me have a good beer
you know a good drink every now and then
um and and but you can also do that and
participate and be a guy's guy without
harming people or animals yes and it's
like almost shifting the mindset of like
what does masculinity even mean because
really truly when i think of masculinity
i think of a protector someone who
doesn't need to show off to
prove their masculinity yeah and to be
like look i can kill this innocent
animal and look how manly i am whereas
you you're like i'm gonna do activism
and show people the injustices in the
world both animal and human yeah you
know that you're seeing day to day in
your life from your own experience even
and like that that's so masculine and i
think that's one reason why so many
people flocked to you because it was
like wow this actually makes so much
more sense yeah and i do think a lot of
my experiences have
been been able to enable me to activate
that true uh compassion inside of me and
i guess i always been compassionate as a
little boy um but
there's nothing
um nothing more sad than someone that
takes advantage or
becomes a bully and
and destroy something or part of
something that simply is doing
absolutely nothing for this beautiful
place that we all have to share call
home because i don't know about you i
don't have a million dollar ticket to go
to mars or to escape to another planet i
have no and i have no desire
to go space travel you know what i mean
like i want to take care of home and i
want us to be more alert and to do what
we can to save this planet for sure and
there's a lot of just like walls and
bears both in things like the prison
system that still need so much
improvement through our systems and then
also with the animals and how much
there's so much facade and lies that are
just told so much to help people feel
good about the animals that they're
eating like oh look this look at this
happy cow on this milk carton and you
know the propaganda is real it's so real
and it's actually fascinating to me how
there's this growing movement of people
thinking that veganism is propaganda and
that you know it's actually the meat
industry that's just trying to be honest
and tell you how great their for their
food really is so good for you yeah
yeah money influences you right if you
follow the money of the articles in the
marketing you'll see that there are
lobbyists and special interest groups
definitely trying to
push this certain agenda and propaganda
um because why would you want to first
of all you can get enough protein for
plants uh you can definitely feel
fulfilled you can definitely thrive
you're not gonna wither away i'm a
pretty solid dude you know um and
there's a lot of people like me in our
positions from drew to more people and
other friends in our community that show
that you can be a human being and simply
be sustainable healthy and strong
as [ __ ] on a plant-based diet without
harming or digesting something that's
going to take you 72 hours to get out
your system anyway nothing logical if
you look at your hands our physical
attributes for our design through
natural selection and this is made for
picking
fruits it's not made for a clawing it's
not made for tearing apart animals
nothing exactly and you don't have to
digest the system to digest something
alive you showed me a human being that
can take a live animal with this heart
beating in the tendon still and digest
it fully within 24 hours and i said
you're right we're we're apex predators
we're carnivores you can't show me that
we need man-made tools to trap them and
we need man-made tools to cook them up
and cook up these carcinogens it just
makes no logical sense or show me a
human being that can breathe salt water
go grab a grouper a tuna or a salmon
come back eating it without cutting up
the skin and i said yeah we're made to
digest this marine life we're not
yeah so
absolutely and i also think about things
like um what's hidden from
the animal like from us about the animal
agriculture industry like slaughterhouse
footage and stuff and how you know when
where people are saying oh animal foods
is so nourishing for us so good for us
but but then they're not showing the
process of an animal being dismembered
and slaughtered because no one wants to
see that you know there's a difference
between like a hunting page it's like
look at me you know the whole masculine
about like hunting but then there's also
this other level of like there's a
reason that you're not like look at this
animal i just sliced their throat and
taking the skin off because it's not
appetizing to us and we all know it's
like that was an innocent animal that
didn't want to die yeah
and there's nothing natural about buying
a piece of steak or anything from a
grocery store that you didn't have to
get your hands dirty you have to cut up
yourself and you again you need man-made
tools to get it from that source to your
your plate
and again listen no judgment to those of
you that do eat meat out there you know
it is my hope that you do consider
the fact that there's really nothing
natural about it but also the impact it
has on the environment and hopefully you
can do better and make better decisions
because i used to eat meat but you know
i don't anymore you know right so when
you're speaking
about veganism online like who do you
imagine that you're speaking to and like
who are you trying to reach specifically
i don't try to reach anyone i just
walk my walk and if someone comes into
my tribe or energy um hopefully i'm
influenced on them like i was telling
lauren earlier i'm at a point in my life
i attract my tribe and my tribe finds me
and that's just such a beautiful synergy
it really is like an energy the energy
you have about yourself you attract it
yeah totally and it is and they'll find
you and you'll find them and that's
what's been happening for a while now
like when you force it and you run it
like a business model it's gonna fail
because it's not authentic and you have
to be your authentic self
so when talking about problems within
our system in america and then also food
related can you address or talk about
your thoughts on like food insecurity in
marginalized communities and
if that relates to plant foods at all or
where do you think we should go from
there i think more so
we're at a point where food security is
a global thing too not just a local
thing here in america specifically um
and what the pandemic has shown too how
globally fool's insecurity is where
we're feeding livestock we're taking our
resources from our biggest and most
powerful and richest nations to
feed into this system and we're supposed
to be the smartest
animals on earth but we're kind of like
the dumbest that do this right because
we truly have enough resources to feed
the world
but here in america i think it's close
to over 40 million
which is defined food security in
america as people that go to sleep at
night in this day and age post pandemic
food security was differently defined
pre pandemic but post pandemic is
someone that's hungry going to sleep
hungry at night i think it's close to
over 40 million
americans now that go to sleep hungry
and that's a big number but we have
money
digital currency to fund other projects
but we can't even take care of our own
and and historically yeah you have
everything from food deserts to unfair
business practices from redlining and
more where you have these stores and you
don't have access to grocery stores
where that single mother
one or four would need to travel
to get access to fresh produce and more
but that's what's happening and now with
this disruption in the supply chain and
more food security is spilling over into
other communities not just marginalized
communities a lot of communities out
there specifically and and even more
people don't realize there are military
families relying on food
from
food pantries and other non-profit and
organizations trying to feed them
because they don't have enough money to
feed their families military families
people that are fighting
uh to protect us in some capacities
which a lot of people don't know that
and so it's becoming yeah it's becoming
a bigger issue
where
food in itself
and it's really mainly due to this
pandemic too it's just getting more and
more worse out there and a lot of people
are simply not making it in life and we
need to be more sensitive to that and to
do what we can to really address these
issues because it is a policy chain we
need to be more aggressive with these
people that will elect whether you elect
somebody on the left or elect somebody
on the right you know you need to really
pressure them to be more
involved to change these different
policies so what are your thoughts on
some policies that need to be changed a
lot of different as far as reallocating
money uh in terms of creating more
uh sources and i mean look inflation's
at i think the all-time high has ever
been we can control some of these things
starland needs big farmers and big
industries
have an impact on exactly
what we
do when as a consumer specifically so we
can effect policy change at that level
to make uh food more sourcely available
we can also have some
more aggressive practices to stop this
price collagen and stuff like that and
also make food more accessible and more
affordable
not driven by one
set of group of big five grocers
specifically we need to open up the
playing field too and also
even more promote better practicing and
farming specifically the farmers too
they're going through a lot they gotta
but they have to tighten up their
buckles too like it's just a a very
complex system that we can change but
we're so driven on capitalism that we're
not we're not making any changes
specifically to that so i don't know if
capitalism is the problem per se
personally i feel like there's a
difference between like true free market
capitalism and like crony capitalism and
problems within capitalism like powerful
lobbying industries through
um like the meat and dairy industry and
the processed food industry so like for
me i personally would like to see
like these lobbying powers to like kind
of fade away and then shift things like
food subsidies if we're really going to
subsidize
foods then we should instead of
subsidizing foods that are making people
unhealthy like you know from what these
powerful lobbyists have influenced as
with processed foods and the meat and
dairy industry
why not subsidize foods that are
actually going to make people well
because i agree yeah i agree and also we
have to be more aggressive with
education because people don't realize
when you go inside a perimeter of the
most
average grocery store that's where it's
expensive processed food is expensive
yeah to make a processed food it's like
why to eat a frozen tv dinner uh
whatever uh whatever frozen food is
expensive um uh worn out to eat it's
expensive but if you stay outside the
perimeter eat more whole food
plant-based stay in the veggies and
fruit out it's actually not that it's
that expensive well i think for people
in comparison yeah in comparison i think
for people like calorie wise they're
like i only have three dollars here am i
gonna buy mcdonald's burger to feed my
child or a head of broccoli very real
yeah and so like the food subsidies
thing is just so out of balance because
like we do see so many people we have so
many sick people and unwell people in
america in general and then add on top
of it if you don't have the finances to
buy healthy food like this is where we
really need to be changing something
so yeah you're on the go that one dollar
burger 99 cents burger looks pretty
attractive for sure if you're you don't
have access to the local grocery you
know quick 15 minute lunch break you're
working for amazon whatever and you're
like damn i just need something to eat
the last thing in your mind is eating
healthy
for sure and it's just more difficult
it's definitely more difficult we're
gonna get higher calories become more
satiated from that process stuff and
then you're also gonna be one of those
demographics eventually being admitted
to this health system this bloated
health system that's just
could be really corrected through
lifestyle changes and preventive care we
got to get back to preventive care
preventive care i agree
i think a lot of times it's kind of like
oh universal health care is the answer
but i think but i think there's so many
other things that we should change first
like we were just talking about if we're
gonna uproot because i think a lot of
times people try to compare us to like
you know certain european countries that
have free health care but we are so
different to those countries in so many
ways that we most countries are not like
us that we have such diverse so many
different diverse cultures with
different ways of living and then on top
of that
um
there's factors related to in the
healthcare system you don't know what
you're paying for you don't you don't
know how much certain things are like
you go to hospital and they won't tell
you how much something costs and
actually and actually i had a friend
visiting from another country and she
got hurt she went to the hospital needed
an mri and she's like well how much is
this going to cost i don't have
insurance and they're like we can't tell
you that yeah that's that's what it is
so then so that's my wheelhouse they
they don't know at that level at that
position that admitting clerk don't know
what that drg or revenue code is going
to cost yeah a heart open heart surgery
can range anywhere between 50 grand to
100 grand they don't know that depending
on what they got to do depending on the
health system the region what they have
to do
your age a lot of factors and factors in
that place medicare laws localities
there's so much consider contractually
the payer what they have in agreement
with the hospital is just a lot of
factors so many factors so many factors
so of course that admitting clerk is not
going to be able to tell your friend or
my friend or anyone whatever is
happening with them when they're being
admitted what is going on because
they're they're just not qualified or
skilled or educated or in that position
to say hey yeah
i know what's happening that goes bump
up to a different level right
that health system for per se but that
goes to show you that
listen there is
money these health systems and these
payers
are
making money off of sick people
so when you go to university i'm
actually pro university healthcare when
you go to universal healthcare you you
eliminate
that whole human psychology psyche of
wanting to cut corners and make money
and to monetize often sick people we
should not be monetizing offering anyone
sick healthcare is definitely a human
right to me and if anything that we've
seen in this pandemic is the fact that
we all should have access to quality
health care because it's going to make a
better and healthy community i agree
with you that we should all have access
to it it's more about like
is this the answer and a couple things i
want to ask so when you said about the
the front clerk can't know how much they
cost do you feel like though there are
certain things that could be a lot more
transparent like there's some hospitals
that would be like charging 200 for
ibuprofen yeah so that's a policy change
right that's actually something that
happened in the last administration they
did they did a policy change at a
federal level but i don't know if they
have to how much has to happen on like a
state level because obviously that plays
a role sure um but i think that that
that plays a big role with in regards to
the costs and things being bloated and i
think you're right there's a lot of
corruption in regards to
money and everything like that but i
guess when i go back to things like
universal health care i look at
the health care that we have in america
and compare it to other countries and
the healthcare they have when it's
government-run and when it's not like
necessarily driven as much by something
like if you're just going to say a
blanket statement like profit i feel
like there's more layers to that but
when you look at america
almost universally people are flocking
here to get our health care yeah then
the other way around like you're not
gonna find someone from texas going to
canada for healthcare because
we have such a free market system like
there's a there's a reason why america
has like some of the biggest and most
amazing inventions and technological
advances it's because the reward is so
great and when you take away the reward
of like
making such a big risk doing such a big
risk to like invent something like
life-saving technological
equipment for surgeries or a drug that
is life-saving right things like that if
you take away the reward being so great
and it all just kind of like it's not
about profit
then you lower the quality like i look
at personal things when they're like
government-run i look at like the dmv
and the u.s post office and the quality
of service that you get when it's
government-run versus something like ups
that's privately run and they're like
look i want people to choose ups because
i'm all about business and i'm about
trying to bring provide the best product
and service and then there's like
incentive it's like a natural
desire to like do your best when it
comes to
things like that so that's kind of my
thoughts but i think a lot of people
fail to realize because you if you do go
with a universal health care model you
don't eliminate the free market the free
market is still developed people in
canada still have the option to go to
elect if they don't want to wait on
their surgery or whatever they're going
through because we do live in a society
where
all humans especially in the western
region are number one lee impatient
people want what they want right now you
know and that's the problem that's
people like oh i need to have a surgery
and look surgery is important but there
are definitely some some things that can
wait a week or a couple of days where
you're not a priority but people want
they expect that right away and that's
the some of the uh talking points of
people that are opposed to universal
healthcare are pushing out there and
you're not going to eliminate the free
market if you have the money to go pay a
surgeon sooner than later to have
whatever you need to have done or even
to get access to more medicine quicker
than waiting
24 to 48 hours i kind of blamed the
whole business model of amazon people
when they click on that button yeah they
expect the same day to get serviced or
even restaurants fast food casual
everything people are just we're we live
in a society where people have no
patience
no patience and and it's spilling over
in other in industries and communities
including health care so free market is
not going to be unlimited it's still
going to be there but then you have
universal health care and this is going
to make a more better community because
that little boy or girl that might have
some type of virus like you know
whatever what are we talking covert or
something new in the future kobe 800 i
don't know
and and but when you have and so they
may have a different family background
where they mom and dad may don't have a
hmo you know they may have a ppo or a
pos or
or a free market or self-care i mean
self-insured where they may don't have
access to the same quality health system
but you integrate that in that same
community that school system that kid
can have an impact whatever they're
carrying on your kid but when you have
quality universal health care everyone's
going to be protecting in some type of
umbrella where you don't have to really
worry about little things like that so
it the model works but the free market
still would be there so do you think
that it should be like um raising taxes
to cover health care for all but then
keep health care and a lot of
practices within healthcare privatized
not necessarily government-run but it's
free for everyone but it's not
necessarily free like it's not free
because someone's paying for it well
well let's be honest the whole tax code
and the tax issue in general was
probably the first thing that
left or right should have dismantled and
and presented itself before that
overhaul of healthcare years ago we we
had to really address that but also be
very transparent about like i said i'm
this digital currency this borrowing
money from here and there yeah there's a
lot involved with taxes and that's our
money as you us citizens but we do have
resources more than we know it you know
and and we can fund these things or even
reallocate to a different part yeah um
that instead of very bloated bloated
bloated super bloated military um yes
actually i was gonna bring that up
because that's i agree with you there's
one factor we don't we don't need new
f-16s every year
or new tanks every year so much of our
tax dollars gets allocated towards
military funding and i don't i i
definitely don't consider myself an
expert to know how much money we should
be allocating towards it it's the
biggest budget i believe it is the
biggest in the world because we're kind
of we kind of act like the police of the
world we have our military infiltrated
everywhere in the
yeah so i'm with you if we're gonna do
more things like making it uh more
affordable and available like more types
of um
types of services available towards all
because right now you have the ability
if you have emergency care you're not
like you're not going to be denied
service no matter who you are but let's
talk about things like surgeries and
things like that yeah there's a few
things i want to say one like i think
it's hard for us to compare to like
another country that it works for
because they don't spend so much money
on the military so i'm with you if we're
going to go that way let's at least
i mean because because our military's
protecting them anyway yeah i know so
they don't have to spend canada they
don't have a big military that's like
america's going for us over here yeah
right but we have to spend the money on
that so like it's so hard to know like
how are we to be like oh just you know
pull out because really there's a lot of
people who hate america and there's a
lot of threats there so there's not
about canada i'm not talking about
canada but you know what i'm saying like
we have we're infiltrated a lot of
places yeah we're big brothers to
protect yeah so i i understand that
aspect but hence why it's hard for us to
just compare to another country that it
works for so there's some people in
canada we're just using ken as an
example who really likes their health
care and there's some people who really
hate it because i've you know i've
definitely spoken to people who are like
takes two or three months to get a
surgery that i really need whereas in
america you could just go and get it
right away and part of that or it might
be that surgeon and part of that not
that interruption i'm sorry but part of
that too because i talk to those same
people yeah it's because they have a
special doctor they want to go to it's
just a lot you got to consider those
factors yeah there's always layers and
factors for sure and i feel like this is
such a complex topic
but it's really fun i actually find it
so fascinating because there's so many
details that's hard to understand and i
want to unpack it and really understand
it because there's layers to it right
yeah but i forget what was i saying i
was um basically just mentioning that
like it comes at a cost if
if we're all paying higher taxes to be
able to do this universal
covering healthcare and the government
decides what you can pay for or not
that's when you start having delays and
things because they have to decide what
you can who can get it how many times a
month how many patients can they take
per thing and because we are already
like so in debt and because another the
hugest factor is that we're the most
unhealthy nation we have the most
obesity the most diabetes the most heart
disease the most prescription drug use
by far like i was actually looking at
the stats we the amount of americans
that take prescription drugs
regularly it's significantly higher than
any other nation and so when you factor
all that in i think it's like
the idea is nice but i'm just not sure
if that's necessarily the first thing we
should do
i'm not like against it i'm not like
definitely not i'm more just like i
think there's other things like
substituting healthy food like you said
preventative care that i think is like
far
definitely where we should start first
yeah for sure i mean yeah i mean because
you
you're not you're just putting a
band-aid even if you have a health care
you're just putting a band-aid or a
bigger problem yeah you have to get to
the root of the problem which is eat
healthier yes and we have such a
crippled health care system it's total
sick care and it's just like we rely on
it so much so so much so many people
having to go all the time
and if we could prevent that we also are
one of those nations that very rarely do
any kind of natural alternatives you go
to a regular hospital holistically yeah
it's like this is it
surgery
countries aren't like that so maybe but
how would you what would you think would
be a good way to shift that
like policy wise well policy-wise is we
probably need to be
rewarding more
uh
medical students to go more into
holistic care one thing is what i've
been seeing a lot though there are a lot
more holistic providers coming out
and and of um
coming these these med students are
practicing and opening up a more
holistic approach and and but you're
right we are driven off of uh drugs and
and
food is is really medicine over
what should be prescribed as a drug over
medicine and don't get me wrong um
western medicine and modern medicine in
general has definitely saved a lot of
lives and has been very influential in
the human race thriving in different
capacities
but
we do and we should always look at more
holistically the the approach
of holistic medicine before any thing
that we are
conditioned to think in black and white
that we learned in med school just take
this pill
uh for whatever something that you're
experiencing that this might not even be
a symptom that just probably needs
tweaking in your diet yeah and so like
medical doctors are not taught this in
medical school and this is something we
talk to the plant-based doctors and
physicians about all the time they're
like
and actually dr clapper is trying i was
talking about him
about this with him on the podcast that
he's like going into um universities and
teaching this that look there's
preventative ways to help the patients
and actually it's going to help them so
much better to thrive and not have to
need to rely on medication that's not to
say that medication is never going to be
helpful but just to see like a balance
that other some other countries seem to
do better than us yeah no and i i
remember 10 years ago we probably had
like
two percent vegan doctors and now it's
like
so many down vegan doctors and
plant-based diets so many and so that
goes to show you because even then we
was talking about like we need more
vegan doctors and more rds and nutrition
just clinicians that are plant-based and
focus on food being the medicine yeah
and look where we're at today and the
same thing with what dr klapp is talking
about we can take that same business
model um as a community that we're
involved in and start applying that with
the holistic approach we can get there
just like we have thousands of vegan
doctors now and we can get there now
where we have a lot of more holistic
doctors with the same type of approach
right yeah wow i i so agree with you so
on the same page there it would be great
if we could see some
like um i don't know if policy changes
the right
thing but when it comes to medical
schooling like there is actually even
corruption within lobbying powers within
that do you know much about that like
being in the course it's always going to
be influential in fact a friend of mine
i was just talking to the other day and
it goes down to the medicine and animals
and stuff like there are committees that
approve of if you have the financial
means to
um and this gets into student loans
and how
unfair and some of these predatory
practices these banking institutions
kind of
make you
take out these massive amounts there are
people with three hundred thousand
dollars in debt and student loans it's
such a problem it's crazy just to serve
a community and just you're you're going
to school to be in a way consider a
public servant to try to help better
your community by being a provider to
just be there and kind of the liaison to
trying to heal whatever issues they're
going in but you got to go into debt 300
000 and that is it's kind of yeah i feel
like some a lot of times though there's
this notion that like everyone needs to
go to college to be successful like it
because because that's not true because
in the beginning back when you know
college was getting really popular
parents were like oh yeah you go to
college you get a job right away as soon
as you go to college if you graduate
you're guaranteed a job and then
everyone's kids started going to college
it was like oh everyone has a degree and
now it's not as valuable now you need a
master's for it to be valuable now you
need a phd for you to be i actually know
people with phds that don't have that's
still held hot drugs they have shitty
jobs yeah and i think it really depends
it depends on the field like if you're
going into a phd within a job that just
doesn't really have a high demand for a
job you know it's just something that
you have to consider if it's worth it
yeah and so i think it would be good i
definitely want to encourage my children
to just do what they feel is right for
them and not be like look you all need
to go to college to be successful for
some kind of egoic thing of like look my
kid graduated college instead that
business model is outdated yeah i think
it's true in itself to show that you
simply depends on what you're doing yeah
going to a school to be disciplined and
to learn and to be amongst peers that
have information and professors that
have experience it's definitely valuable
i'm not taking that away but there's
definitely things in the world you can
do without requiring yourself to go to
an institution there are very successful
people that don't have college degrees
and that are killing them absolutely
yeah for sure and one thing too that's
the newest business model in corporate
america that i have been seeing because
still tied to that community in some
capacities is a lot of these employer
groups whether small and large are going
more so often experience
long goals are the days if you have 10
years experience but no degree you can't
get that position they're like no you
have the experience that's equated in
fact that's better than having a degree
specifically totally and there's still
something that would take a risk if you
have a degree because
long gone a lot of days in some
capacities like well you need to have 10
years experience in this degree how do
you expect me to get the experience are
you going to give me the chance
i know how how you know it doesn't make
sense it's like you're going around
you can't you can't really sorry
outdated practices and there are more
companies more uh compassionate and
looking more
for candidates that simply want to
you look at those two women that gave
you a chance exactly yeah and i wonder
if your view of women stems from seeing
how hard working your mom was it does it
does i i have some pretty kick-ass women
in my family including my sisters my
older sisters and more uh but in general
like even my team that's around my team
with women that work for me um
i um just feel like women and again this
is my own bias i don't deny that i just
feel like they go beyond the call to
duty to really get to the problem to
root up like a healthcare provider my
pcps growing up from my pediatrician to
my internists
you know if you have a rash here or you
have something that hurts hearing muscle
here they want to rule out they want to
just see like they do take a holistic
approach most of the time they do they
want to really try to find a solution
versus like ah come back in like a
couple months if it hurts then we'll
we'll do an mri like yeah the typical
morning yeah yeah yeah exactly or okay
here here's a painkiller you know you
know versus like no i want to get to it
and most the time again probably going
to get [ __ ] for this
but
um i feel like women do go beyond the
call of duty versus the average male
doctor that probably wouldn't know oh
that's an interesting yeah yeah for sure
i mean again you're like i'm hearing you
it's not a blanket statement i know but
i'm here i'm going to get [ __ ] for this
and i'm like yeah i don't think so i
don't know i really then he's not like
oh okay maybe somebody will have yeah if
you look in your own life from
everything so just it's just you know
women just have that it's just part of
your dna to nurture and want to really
research and get and really try to solve
something um yeah interesting yeah
that's just my experience from the women
i grew
our experiences shape a lot a lot of how
we view the world i mean you have such a
unique life experience coming from
growing up in a hard situation let's
just say something simple like that and
then
being
incarcerated and understanding the
prison system and then working for the
healthcare industry and being a
passionate vegan and caring about you
know marginalized communities so you
have such a unique life experience
so i mean just kind of rounding out a
little bit because of all your
experiences and the passions you have
for like specifically let's talk about
human rights of like people in
marginalized communities what
specifically what would be like one of a
couple of the most big the biggest
things that maybe someone listening
could do or something that you would
like to see change either on a policy
level or just like on a broader societal
societal level i think we're now at the
point that we need to understand um as
uh we're talking within u.s uh i mean
because policy can be globally and
everyone is in a different region and
have their own shitty elected officials
but i can only speak on where i reside
and and where and this is in america
i think
we're now more than ever realized just
how important it is to be really
independent thinkers of the fact that
whether you're talking red magga a blue
maga
right wing lovering at the same chicken
the extremes either way yeah there i
mean if these people simply don't have
your best interest at heart and it's
really about amplifying your local
communities
and and also
really uh holding
at a local level
these people that you do decide to maybe
vote for and elect and put them more
accountable
because the the highest office in the uh
position in america
sure they have influence but they're
they're the bigger problems are the
senators and then the people in the
house and stuff like that those are the
ones that actually are writing these
laws or pushing this agenda and it's
usually backed by lobbyists and all of
that um and it's sad because it's really
no
simple solution you know to this
gridlock this that we have in in dc
specifically these are simply people
that are just
don't have your best interests at heart
and and and with that being said
you should probably be more kind and
open and empathetic to
your fellow citizens and neighbors
versus these pieces of [ __ ] that really
don't care about you you know what i
mean like whether you're talking about
john doe or jane doe
realize that you all in this this fight
against this system that really don't
really have your best interests at heart
they they don't they don't yes i think a
lot of people know that i don't know if
i would say like none of the people who
are in office don't have our best
interests at heart but a lot of times
there's a lot of corruption there so i i
think like 99.9 don't have the best
they're really influenced by uh big
institutions and lobbyists and and yeah
and more uh industries
is what's really shaping america yeah
but the beautiful thing
the silver lining not to make everybody
depressed but the silver lining is the
fact that social media has helped people
with bigger platforms what are we
talking the rogans of the world or the
ls and the doms of the world or anyone
with a platform
is making and putting pressure like
you're actually countering and fighting
uh mass media with social media and
having influences on these micro pockets
of people that are not going to just sit
and and take it and follow the leave of
this agenda and this propaganda that's
being pushed i agree
there's so much propaganda it's a lot of
resistance so much propaganda uh but
there is a fight and we have to you have
to make that decision are you going to
be on this side of the fence or that
side of the fence and i just wish more
people come together to realize that
independently we're better to fight
against these people in these powerful
positions versus divided because they
are trying to cost a vision division is
very real the division is intentional
very absolutely intentional
people don't realize that if we really
do come together we are so much more
powerful than they then they try to make
us realize they try to act like we're so
they want us to be divided because we
don't have any power but we have so much
power correctively
yes and i think a lot of people get
discouraged because they're like look
what can i do like you know as far as
like government differences it's very
difficult to make that much change like
on a personal level other than like what
you're saying voting for what you
believe is the best it's going to help
bring help other people but i like to
also look at like look on an individual
level how can we help through our own
dollars through our own decisions in
supporting companies that are helping
people in poor communities dollar
influences consumers influence for sure
what you buy your dollar has a big
influence in different ways there's
definitely things you can do as a
consumer to have that yeah what do you
what do you suggest do you have any
thoughts on like specific organizations
that people can support
um or things that they can do on a
personal level i think one of the most
things you can start by and you have to
identify your why and what you want to
see change if you want to see
climate change address and you want to
see a better environment and and to help
that it starts with your diet it starts
with your own education and stuff like
that if you want to see better policy
change or have influence in health care
it starts with maybe making phone calls
and gathering
facebook groups and or creating your own
organ community to help fight and to
hold hospital systems accountable
because a lot of things are affected by
medicare laws that comes from
the government specifically if you want
to see other changes
to
more access to
grocers and and farmers get more local
farmers be supported like putting money
back into your local community with
local farmers over going to a big store
like whole foods or
a big chain specifically it starts right
right there in your own ecosystem so
there's little things you can do to
really help drive and really make
your community you have to think about
your community locally first before
you're thinking about uh domestically
and then internationally yeah it can be
easy to just like put your hands up in
the air and be like well i can't help on
a wider bigger level but then kind of
just forget the people right in front of
you that you meet on day-to-day basis
people who are in need your neighbors
yes your neighbors people that you come
in contact with if you're at the grocery
store and you notice a single mom who's
struggling in some capacity like help
them out if you have the means to do
that yeah and buy local all the time too
like those local businesses local
businesses yeah and actually that's
something that that pandemic has caused
a lot of issues with because the riches
got richer and the small businesses
really suffered through all the
especially
this is and this is why a lot of us are
very angry because you a lot of small
businesses from our our friends and
family to us in general uh was crushed
in so many capacities by what happened
uh the last couple years
um and i
i can't stress it enough it became
personal you know because these are
people livelihoods and they have to rely
on what i mean the people got got to pay
rent mortgages and more and things being
unfairly shut down in some capacities uh
even to this day there are some things
happening that i just don't agree with
right yeah
it's really heavy to talk about all the
different things there's so much that
need improvement like you said
healthcare and so many people suffering
not getting the health care that they
need and the incarcery incarceration
rate yeah um and welcome to life i know
i know sometimes you can just be like i
wish that you know you could solve all
the world's problems and we all do most
of us do but a lot of us really don't
and that's an and that's the biggest
takeaway is that you got to realize
again there are some people that simply
don't care and
that's fine
but we're not going to be able to
convince everyone to get on board with
just being a decent kind human being
there are definitely some people that
thrive off of disruption narcissism and
the world being in chaos so you're a
realist or an optimist
you know
i am just a human i'm a human yeah i
feel like i'm both i'm i'm a human uh
far as
i'm definitely leaning more towards
being a realist in the fact that
um
as optimists as we want to be it's just
simply
look we're never going to see a complete
vegan world and stuff like that you need
i'm i'm just more realistic because
human beings are wired to let you down
yeah i i definitely lean more towards
optimism sure but i have a lot of
realism within me like as well that like
i try to look at situations with a
realistic point of view but at the end
of the day i'm like but optimistically
it's going to get better yeah and
there's things in different areas you
can definitely be optimism for being
optimistic and even manifest you know i
mean but there's a lot of other things
that simply can't be out of your heart
yeah my husband is like you for sure
we're going on a date tonight by the way
well i wouldn't call it i don't know so
i don't have a date not a date we're
just going on a friend's date no i know
a friend but but i'm just letting you
guys know uh here i am a lonely guy a
single dog dad hey put your application
in no i'm just kidding
no but we're going on a date tonight
yeah like a quadruple andrew and i you
and then you have a friend which i'm
really excited to meet and it's gonna be
really fun i'm sure we're gonna get
delvin way more because andrew's a
realist like you and he he's so fun to
talk to about all these conversations so
can you talk a little bit about being
single cause i know that's something you
talk about online that's a hope a
different podcast
you know it's like we could talk a whole
lot we honestly could talk about day
about yeah so i am single and what i
define as self-partnered
uh just like i had a uh
kind of organically
went against resistance with the
masculinity thing like i'm kind of like
in my own way organically and i say this
humbly kind of redefining what it means
to be single
it's okay to be happy and single you
don't have to have
a partner per se or b because a lot of
us are again we've been conditioned and
wired to believe that you need to have a
partner
there are people in the that are now
practicing multiple partners in order to
have that companionship but there's
companionship and love in yourself and
you can certainly thrive and have fun by
yourself whether you're taking yourself
to a movie or dinner by yourself or
going up the hike of one of these
beautiful trails by yourself you can
find truly peace and fun and just a
beautiful experience by yourself but you
have to know
who you are and but there are also
people that are wired to need to be
dependent on other human beings and i'm
just not wired to be dependent well i
think your message is really powerful
because i think there's a lot of people
maybe specifically more often women but
not always um kind of feel this sense of
like there's something wrong with them
or like everyone's pressuring me yeah
and so when you give this outlook of
like look what i've heard you say like
self partnering partnering is that how
you say partner partnering and the way
that you explain like going on hikes for
yourself and loving it and finding that
beautiful like there's such a mindset
involved through the way that you choose
to like love yourself and um not shame
not have shame involved in like what you
yeah you're gonna miss out on experience
just because you know don't miss out on
that great movie like go see you take
yourself to the movie or stream it or
whatever or you know and sure
uh there's pros and cons to that there
there are times that you know you do
want to have that companionship
but don't settle you know and and that's
where i met in my life where
um i've been single now happily single
um for like close to six years i think
five six years um
and i have met some amazing women that
would have been amazing partners but
it's not them it's me and the the key
here though the key men and women all
you guys listening to this
be transparent and honest with that
person
or people or where you at in your life
uh about you don't lie don't say it's me
against the world when it's not like
just be honest about where you at in
your life and it's okay to be single but
still to have that experience of
different companionships if that's what
you want right you know and it's really
key to
starting off with a foundation of
friendship before anything that's
beautiful
all right so one more thing that i
really want to get to before we finish
this podcast is can you tell me about
your book deal that you have coming out
yeah
it's such a real experience like never
in a million years if you told me as a
kid i'm gonna be an author
uh on one of the biggest publishers
publishing houses in the world i i would
tell you no way you know like
me
what am i gonna talk about being from
chicago at five years old so if you told
me as a kid but
it's so surreal like and
i don't think people understand the
um
the very
intense
process that's involved with a book deal
like a
real book deal in terms of the
proposal that's presented to these
publishers because you writing a micro
mini book
that includes marketing analysis it
could
include sample chapters it includes the
arc and more um and i
was able to be a part of that that
process where we got you know a pretty
great book deal what's the book about
what's it gonna be called so the book is
called eat what elephants eat it's
actually coined off from a food company
that most of you may or may not know but
we have one of the most
amazing
food companies
start-up food companies where we teach
people how to eat plant-based we have
rds and food coaches on staff that take
you through this amazing very simple
onboarding process from whether you're a
family of four to a college student or
more but our mission is to make
plant-based eating
not only accessible but more importantly
affordable and this is part of that arm
of that food company so we're going to
talk about everything from recipes and
food and cooking to
the whole foundation of redefining what
plant-based food is to
your transition to how i arrived at
veganism we're going to talk about a lot
of stuff and you're going to learn more
about me from my origins to even my
involvement
in in social justice and and activism
and more so it's a really to me and what
the publisher
we deem it as is truly like a
documentary in the book and it's going
to be a really beautiful experience
that's really awesome are you going to
touch a little bit on your vegan
transformation as well because we're
going to talk about all of that you know
about the transformation which we didn't
even get into in this episode but i i do
want you to touch a little bit on about
like how you became a triathlete and
yeah yeah
yeah i used to kick ass on the traffic
triathlon circuit as iron man triathlete
and more and i took the last four to
five years off to focus on my food
company my brand because under this food
company
you're going to have
not only
our 11 000 subscribers that continue to
grow
but we have
service line 2 which is our superfoods
that's coming out at the end of this
year
and also service line 3 and 40's dbas
which is our juicy smoothie bars as well
as our restaurants and then you're going
to have this amazing book that you're
going to have access to that's going to
have a
open open concept of amazing
non-judgmental well for someone that's
either vegan or vegan curious or some
someone that's a meat eater we we have
everything for you guys we welcome you
with love that's incredible so it's like
all your story encompassing including
helping people how to do it it's a
beautiful guy it's a beautiful
experience that's exactly what it is
that's really cool and okay segwaying
just a tiny bit when did you become a
triathlete through everything that you
just told me that you what i got when i
arrived to new york yeah
new york concrete jungle does something
to you for sure wow and how long were
you a triathlete uh
i want to say uh
like eight years yeah yeah like yeah six
to eight years i'll never forget your
transformation photos the before and
after that was like i remember those i
mean i might even put it up right here
people who are watching for sure yeah
incredible yeah you have so many
important messages that i think are
really inspiring for people and helpful
for them to be aware of and start you
know being aware of others going forward
and aware of yourself and yeah i'm just
thankful that i got to have you come
visit i'm so honored to have it we gotta
i feel like there's so much we can talk
about but maybe we can get a part two
you in the states let's do that flying
here was not fun for me
you texted me i text you live
for me yeah yeah it's just so everyone
knows like i said i don't fear anything
in life but i just to me just it's just
when you have my timeline it's just not
natural to fly i hate flying and i've
been on a lot of flights i don't like
flying either i just do not like it it
just doesn't feel natural to me at all
yeah i try my best to avoid it too so so
for me to come here to see you says a
lot it says a lot to me i acknowledged
that i realized that this was a big
thing for you to come here and i feel
very thankful and humbled that you did
yeah i definitely phyllis mitchell thank
you for the invite and it's been a great
experience staying with you and your
family here you guys have been great
awesome oh thank you i'm sure we're
going to continue this conversation that
you guys won't get to hear late into the
night tonight
so great thank you so much for coming on
and i think we're going to end it here
thanks everyone for listening thank you
and thank you very much
[Music]